la réalité virtuelle connaît une
évolution fulgurante c'est pourquoi le
festival mutek a organisé cet événement
où l'on peut découvrir une trentaine de
courts métrages expérimentaux
documentaire mêmes d'animation ces
casques et qui gagnent en popularité
permettent d'observer tout ce qui se
passe autour de nous sur 360 degrés
grâce à la composition de deux images
une pour chaque oeil
on a l'impression d'être plongé au coeur
de l'action ces lunettes en carton sont
aussi en train de démocratiser le médium
là on a en fait ni plus ni moins qu' un
morceau de carton avec des lentilles ou
on peut mettre son téléphone intelligent
comme ceux ci et on est en immersion
le duo québécois félix et paul est déjà
une référence en matière de réalité
virtuelle en amérique du nord mais leur
domaine expertise est encore méconnu
c'est important que de l'évangélisation
sont vu que plusieurs personnes sautent
dans le train de la réalité virtuelle
tout ce qui se passe au niveau du
développement d'affaires en ce moment se
passe aux etats unis donc on a du retard
oui je pense que oui mais aussi les
moins de capitaux aussi c'est une petite
population donc c'est compréhensible
mais en même temps je j'espère que c'est
une industrie qui va se développer ici
avec cet événement qui s'adresse autant
au public qu'aux professionnels uteq
souhaite provoquer des rencontres entre
les compagnies québécoises de cinéma
d'effets spéciaux et de jeux vidéo
l'idée c'est de braquer un peu les
projecteurs sur montréal et de montrer
aux montréalais et aux monts finalement
qu on a tout ici pour être une espèce de
vie en valley la vallée de l'arrêté
virtuelle des artistes indépendants de
partout dans le monde et des acteurs
influents de l'industrie seront à
montréal jusqu'à samedi soir pour
discuter de l'avenir de la réalité
virtuelle ici tanya lapointe
radio-canada mourir